[Music]
yellow Falcon one of your senses tell
you the structu is a killing machine his
armor is impervious to our blusters you
got any ideas red Falcon sure do yellow
Falcon Blue Falcon you remember our
battle at dango Bluff I'll take the legs
you take the blasters
it was fever Creek and I took the legs
make sure you sharp that flank Black
Falcon are you talking to me because I'm
the green Falcon no time for that black
Vulcan purple Vulcan missile battle
formations we're going in hey my Falcon
is green hey hey hey we can talk about
our Falcon colors when we get back to
base Black Falcon right now we got a
mission to do fall into Falcon formation
well here's the issue is that you're
gonna give me an order I'm not gonna
know you're talking to me cuz I'm not in
the Black Falcon come on chill it out
Black Falcon yeah Black Falcon black
first of all I don't like the way you
guys are saying black second of all
there is no Black Falcon I'm green
Falcon Black Falcon homie no one's
trying to get up in your girl here don't
talk to me like that no don't say grill
like that I'm the green Falcon and I
stopping so Black Falcon about it what
the black folk brother I understand what
you're going through
do you know I don't think you do how
would you feel if I called you red
Falcon huh whoa purple Falcon how would
you feel if I called you yellow Falcon
oh that's a racist that was racist
yeah that's racist oh that is racist
that's racist Oh see okay no forget it
Black Falcon out green Falcon hey why'd
that green Falcon fall out of Falcon
formation Black Falcon get on that
report back Black Falcon
Black Falcon come in
you